there is a great diversity of living
beings on our wonderful planet
they can be found almost anywhere in the
depths of the oceans
in the earth's interior and in air
currents high up in the atmosphere
even volcanoes were found to harbor
microorganisms
adapted to the harsh conditions there
there are around 3 million species of
living organisms on earth
some of them of the most fascinating
makeup from primitive bacteria to higher
order vertebrates and anthropods however
it took a long while for this diversity
to establish itself
the evolution of life on earth was
anything but linear
there were periods of higher diversity
as well as periods of almost total
extinction
this was deduced following the analysis
of fossils unearthed at paleontological
digging sites
in the past 540 million years
there have been five major and about 20
minor extinction events
however the most global crisis of our
planet's biosphere occurred much earlier
approximately 2.1 billion years ago
the first living organisms are posited
to have appeared on earth rather early
approximately but not quite four billion
years ago
that is about 400 million years after
the planet's surface had become more or
less suitable for life
even so the earth of that period can't
have looked hospitable barren rocks
dense clouds frequent storms and
earthquakes
and an atmosphere devoid of oxygen made
up of mostly nitrogen
methane and carbon dioxide
this was the age of primitive
microorganisms archaea and bacteria
most of which used an oxygenic
photosynthesis
that is a kind of photosynthesis where
oxygen is not produced
apart from these creatures it is thought
that there were many forms
falling in between that couldn't be
classified as either living beings
or not living objects with a satisfying
degree of certainty
about 2.7 billion years ago their
emerged oxygenic photosynthesis
the kind of photosynthesis familiar to
us where oxygen is produced
this form is still used by the
overwhelming majority of plants
and unicellular algae anaerobic
organisms cannot live in an oxygen-rich
environment
that is why ancient algae used oxygen as
a weapon
they released it as a byproduct of their
life activity
and this waste killed their competitors
this way algae not only protected their
turf
but also spread further to cover larger
areas to dwell on
at first oxygen was spent on oxidation
of rocks in habitats of aerobic
organisms colonies
in this manner oxygen pockets were
formed
small areas of oxidized minerals
gradually
oxygen went on to spread in the
atmosphere oxidizing methane
sulfur compounds and iron not able to
exist in an environment rich in oxygen
most anaerobic organisms died out with
those of them remaining around
confined to underground pockets where
oxygen didn't reach
thus the tables were turned in the
biosphere with the oxygen breathing
organisms becoming the majority and
spreading across
larger areas and the former planet
owners forced to remain in some limited
areas
with the spread of the new organisms the
content of gases like methane and carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere dropped
methane oxidized forming water and
eventually carbon dioxide
with the latter taking active part in
photosynthesis
all this reduced the greenhouse effect
and the earth's surface
considerably cooled the so-called
heronian glaciation started
approximately 2.1 billion years ago
and continued for about 300 million
years until the sun's luminosity and
tectonic makeovers had heated up the
earth
this was a time when single cell
microorganisms were evolving extremely
slowly
constantly thwarted by an occasional
prolonged global ice age
the period has earned a great number of
nicknames like the great oxidation or
oxygenation event
oxygen catastrophe and oxygen crisis to
name but a few
even though not really swift this event
was definitely large scale and global
practically all the biodiversity of the
non-oxygen period was eliminated
and evolution was greatly hampered by
global glaciation for a good billion
years
however in the aftermath there emerged a
more
energy efficient method of nutrition
approximately 540 million years ago
the phanerozoic eons started sometimes
referred to as the period of visible
life
it was peculiar for vigorous evolution
of multicellular species
and in fact it is actually still in
progress
many creatures of that age looked really
bizarre
and didn't resemble any of their today's
descendants
suddenly about 450 million years ago
some unknown factor abruptly interfered
with the act of evolution of life forms
the proposed causes include a cosmic
gamma-ray burst
volcanic activity and even a large
celestial object impact
as it is from 25 to 50 percent of all
living beings became extinct within 7
million years
this series of extinction events dubbed
the ordovician
silurian extinction was hard on
trilobites
mollusks and some other marine
invertebrates of the time
the late paleozoic era that followed
this extinction event
heralded active evolution of flora on
land
the first amphibians and reptiles
emerged in that time too
fishes were actively evolving
establishing their dominance
in all fresh water and saline bodies of
water
approximately 372 million years ago the
so-called devonian extinction started
it occurred in several stages that were
alternately followed by comparatively
peaceful periods
peaceful they may have been but even so
the extinction rate of species was
higher than average
the most likely reason for this
extinction is posited to be this
land plants of the time sported long and
powerful roots which enabled them to
extract nutrients from much deeper down
in the soil than before
when water seeped through soils that
were loosened by plants roots
great amounts of nutrients were washed
into the ocean
as a result algae were positively
thriving there
in the abundance of food and light the
rotting of these algae reduced
oxygen dissolved in the water and the
organisms inhabiting the sea bottom were
simply smothered with nothing to breathe
in the aftermath about 70 percent of the
marine species of that time
are estimated to have died out including
practically all species forming coral
reefs
this triggered global irreversible
changes in the biosphere of the global
ocean
many genera and families vanished
completely
and the vacated space was filled by
others
in the carboniferous period which
followed tree ferns exploded in numbers
all over the planet's surface also there
emerged
gymnosperm trees and conifers it is in
this period that rich deposits of coal
were formed which is still
widely used by mankind and various
industries
speaking about the fauna this was the
time when insects thrived
that's when the giant millipede
arthropleura was around
which measured two and a half meters the
meganura
a giant dragonfly with a wingspan of up
to one meter
and the pulmonary scorpius a scorpion
measuring 70 centimeters
the insects were of these unbelievable
sizes
on account of exceptionally high
concentrations of oxygen in the
atmosphere
which at that time reached a staggering
35 percent
the permian triassic extinction event
also informally referred to as the great
dying
occurred about 251 253 million years ago
marking the transition from the permian
to the triassic period
it proved to be the most massive and
global in the entire history of
multicellular life
diggings show that up to 95 of marine
species
and up to 70 percent of land species
vanished from the face of the earth as a
result
interestingly this disaster was rather
swift by geological standards
it took just up to two hundred thousand
years
later it would take not less than 50
million years for biodiversity to
recover for land species
and about a hundred million years for
marine species
trilobites a great number of marine and
vertebrates and microorganisms were on
the verge of extinction
insects shrank in size they stopped
looking like horror film creatures on
the loose
and instead assumed in appearance of
today's tiny and numerous creatures
the reasons for the permian triassic
extinction event
still haven't been established with
certainty among the proposed hypotheses
we may single out robust volcanic
activity as one of the most likely ones
others worth mentioning are a collision
of our earth with a large celestial
object climate change
and active methane emissions following
biological or tectonic activities
there is no single answer to this
question yet
in the triassic period which followed
the permian triassic extinction event
vertebrates vigorously evolved this is
when archosaurs emerged the prehistoric
saurians crocodiles and dinosaurs were
to evolve from
the triassic period also produced first
mammals
although they were not so widespread at
that time
about 200 million years ago the triassic
jurassic extinction event began
sometimes called the end triassic
extinction
having lasted for approximately 10 000
years
it marked the transition from the
triassic to the jurassic period
the event claimed about half of known
species on the earth of that time
they included various reptiles and
amphibians that vocated a number of
ecological niches
this allowed dinosaurs to establish
their dominance on the planet and
sustain it for the next 130 million
years
incidentally the reasons for the andreas
extinction event are not known either
and in fact there isn't a single
hypothesis today that would sound
sufficiently convincing
the jurassic and cretaceous periods that
followed the triassic jurassic
extinction event were the times when
dinosaurs thrived and flourished
but these giant saurians were not the
sole inhabitants of our planet at the
time
this is when the forefathers of today's
birds flowering plants and corals
evolved
as well as small furry warm-blooded
animals
mammals even though these small
creatures didn't look quite as
impressive compared to tremendous
dinosaurs and all their glory
they firmly held their ecological ground
and steadily progressed on their
revolution
mammals got their chance at the end of
the cretaceous period
that is about 66 million years ago
what occurred then was the most
well-known and a rather large-scale mass
extinction event referred to as the
cretaceous
tertiary extinction event according to
the first and most popular hypothesis
the extinction was caused by a giant
celestial object impact
everyone would have heard of a meteorite
supposedly killing off all dinos
nevertheless there is no hard evidence
in favor of this version
either way the upshot was that all
dinosaurs died out
alongside a great number of conifers
algae and mollusks
the cretaceous tertiary extinction event
heralded the beginning of a new geologic
era
the cenozoic which is still in progress
throughout this era
mammals birds and flowering plants have
been actively evolving
and spreading across the earth mammals
settled all over the planet
inhabiting it literally everywhere from
tropical areas to ice caps of the poles
and from the depths of the oceans and
the planet's interior to air currents up
high
eventually evolution produced mankind
even though you would expect people
today to be enlightened enough
there are still those who do not believe
in evolution
however the theory of evolution is not
something to believe in
it is a scientific theory based on facts
the theory of the evolution of species
has come a long way
and has undergone serious revisions
since its original version proposed by
charles darwin back in 1859
still the basic principles of the theory
are the same
and to date the theory of evolution is
the only
serious scientific theory that
accurately describes the process of the
evolution of species and the origin of
new creatures
according to some scientists we are now
living in the epoch of the sixth mass
extinction event
they also call it the holocene or
anthropocene extinction
thousands of species have died out in
the past 10 000 years
around 900 species have vanished from
the face of the earth in the past
500 years today about 40 percent of
amphibian species and 25 percent of
mammal species are under the threat of
extinction
and it looks like one of the chief
reasons for this is human activity
will humanity be able to tackle this
threat
will life go one step further of the
order as it was always the case after
every major mass extinction event
there is no way of knowing it now the
earth's biosphere
boasts a great potential for recovery
and evolution
which by no means implies that it
doesn't need our care
after all the earth is our only home
dear friends what are your views on all
this
you can always share your opinion in the
comments below
if you've enjoyed the video feel free to
give us a thumbs up
and if you want to be the first to find
out about newly posted videos
you're welcome to subscribe if you
haven't yet done so
let's keep in touch
you